[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue au courant 7,8
culture exceptionnelle un numéro
entièrement consacré un lieu une
histoire une famille elle les breteuil
et durant 26 minutes
nous reviendrons sur le pari un peu fou
d'un jeune homme de 17 ans qui a refusé
de voir son château familial vendu pour
l'ouvrir au public
nous découvrirons certains membres de
cette famille proche du pouvoir royal
durant de nombreuses années nous nous
promènerons au coeur des jardins et nous
ferons foisonner notre imagination en
nous plongeant au coeur des contes de
charles perrault où vous rendez vous
incontournable pour les petits et les
grands lors d'une visite le château de
breteuil appartient à la même famille
depuis 400 ans mais elle est accessible
au public depuis seulement 50 ans au
début des années 1960
un jeune homme de 17 ans henri françois
de bretagne veut le faire découvrir au
grand public
bonjour marc bonjour merci de nous
accueillir au sein de votre château un
site dans lequel vous avez vécu avant de
l'ouvrir au public
oui j'ai vécu quand j'étais jeune
écolier je faisais mes études à paris
mais dès que je le pouvais c'est à dire
dès le samedi après midi et le dimanche
je venais ici dans un château qui était
vraiment ruine à l'époque complètement à
l'abandon mais je tenais ainsi à montrer
que j'avais l'espoir un jour de le
remettre en état et de le restaurer pour
le grand public
et justement cette ouverture au grand
public c'est le 12 avril 1969 et je vous
propose de revenir sur cette histoire
dans notre premier sujet une première
visite après deux ans de travaux le 12
avril 1969 le pari fou du dixième marque
et de breteuil se concrétise ouvrir son
château familial au public est tout à
fait accompagner par séverine on épouse
qui a joué un rôle essentiel dans la
restauration de ce château bel et les
parquets à revers il y avait des
plafonds en revers et je dois dire que
si on n'avait pas été 2 je crois que je
n'y serais jamais arrivé et le premier
élan est venu en 71
lorsque nous avons pu demander au musée
grévin de mead les six premiers
personnages pour évoquer les
et l'histoire du château l'histoire de
la famille donc ça ça nous a fait passer
de 5000 visiteurs à 42000 visiteurs un
château qui le passionnait
henri-françois de breteil pousse son
père à lui donner le site était destiné
à être vendu à des promoteurs il
appelait souvent ce château un éléphant
blanc
il trouvait que c'était vraiment là la
catastrophe que ça avait été le cas pour
lui que tout ce qui se passait avant 14
quand le roi d'angleterre edouard 7
venait c'était de leurs yeux magnifiques
et c deja mais que depuis la guerre
c'était complètement d'un possible ça
lui avait rendu la vie très difficile
henri-françois de breteuil couvent andré
malraux ministre de la culture de classe
et une partie du domaine
à seulement 17 ans le marques qui
souhaitent partager son histoire celle
des bretelles avec les visiteurs dès que
j'arrivais dans dans une bibliothèque
bibliothèque une librairie qu'on me
signaler un livre il y avait même trois
lignes sur les bretons je me précipitais
sur le livre pour voir la table des
matières et voir ce qu'on disait sur
telle ou telle enseigne donc c'est ça
que j'ai voulu raconter à nos visiteurs
comment une famille qui vit ici depuis
quatre siècles va rencontrer l'histoire
de de france ou même l'histoire de
l'europe depuis 1969 le château a
accueilli environ 5 millions de
visiteurs henri-françois de bretagne est
entouré de dix salariés à plein temps
alors le public marc qui pourra revivre
cette histoire de la restauration a
aujourd'hui grâce à une exposition qui
débutera en mai c'est ça le 18 mai nous
allons en quelque sorte les télés les 50
ans d'ouverture par une exposition qui
va nous montrer à la fois le château et
son évolution
comment on est parti d'un château je
dirais en quoi irwin vers un château
maintenant très ouvert avec toute une
série
d'animation notamment pour les enfants à
l'intérieur avec les personnages de cire
à l'extérieur avec les contes de
perrault
donc c'est tout cela qu'on va montrer
dans cette expo ainsi qu'un petit film
qui évoquera un petit peu des différents
reportages qui ont été faits sur le
château et sur ses propriétaires
alors avant de l'ouvrir en 69 vous avez
fait des travaux mais encore aujourd'hui
vous faites toujours des rénovations
c'est en perpétuel changement
le château est un chantier permanent
parce qu'il ya toujours des choses à
faire et finalement curieusement on
manque toujours de place dans un château
on croit qu'on a tout ce qu'il faut et
finalement on se rend compte que
notamment pour les enfants il faut
d'avoir des salles pour les ateliers
il faut avoir des salles pour les
conteuses il faut avoir des messages
pour le pique nique etc
et c'est pourquoi les travaux continuent
avec notamment un bâtiment qui lui avait
brûlé qui était dans un état
épouvantable qui est maintenant
reconstruit qu'on appelle la faisanderie
mais il reste tout l'intérieur de ce
bâtiment à faire et ça sera nous occuper
nous on les trois ou quatre prochaines
années
cette ouverture au public a donc 50 ans
et c'est déjà une réussite
en cinquante ans une douzaine de
visiteurs au début cent vingt mille
annuelle aujourd'hui et la fréquentation
ne cesse d'augmenter
oui c'est exact que le premier jour
c'est une grande émotion parce que même
nos amis du village où d'ailleurs disait
en mai si vous ouvre au public mais vous
n'aurez jamais personne ne vous fatiguez
pas servir à rien et nous avions raison
le sentiment qu'il fallait soit ouvrir
les grilles au grand public et avoir d
une contribution du public pour
restaurer château soit au contraire les
fermer et nous mettre à l'intérieur et à
ce moment là à voir un château qui avait
complètement coulé pour tous écrit
l'enfer un château pour tout ce qui est
le titre que j'ai donné à mon livre et
pour que tous les publics puissent venir
toutes les familles avec finalement
beaucoup de choses
faire découvrir alors depuis 400 ans
certains marquis mais pas seulement ont
obtenu des postes haut placés dans
l'histoire française
moi je propose maintenant qu'on parte à
la rencontre de quelques uns d'entre eux
est que notre nouveau sujet et c'est
votre cousin jean emmanuel charreaux qui
nous les présente à chaque croissant
ministre breteuil le plus illustre c'est
lui louis auguste baron de breteuil
ministre de louis saez diplomate en
europe
il est nommé à la maison du roy durant
cinq ans il sera principal ministre en
remplacement de necker du 12 au 14
juillet 1789 le plus beau souvenir que
l'on puisse avoir de lui ce fait la
table de tai shen également appelé la
table de breteuil confectionné par
neubert est offert en 1779 au baron de
breteuil à l'époque où il était
ambassadeur de france en autriche
louis saez lui avait demandé d'être
médiateur de paix et donc de rétablir la
paix grâce à un traité dans la guerre de
succession de bavière ce que le bar en
bretagne a réussi brillamment à faire
sans qu'aucune goutte de sang ne soit
versée chez les bretons ils sont trois à
avoir eu un rang de ministre le premier
de la famille c'est louise ogre auteuil
contrôleur général des finances du roi
louis xiv
charles a n'a que 8 ans en 1789
parce qu'il était mineur son château et
mis sous séquestre par les
révolutionnaires il lui sera rendu
intacte à sa majorité
ce jeune charles de breteuil nous le
retrouvons ici en 1821 dans la
bibliothèque
il est dans son habit bleu de préfet et
il sera nommé père de france par louis
xviii en 1823 un roi alors impotents qui
se déplaçait en fauteuil roulant charles
de bretagne est un proche collaborateur
du souverain français
il est alors l'un des principaux
conseillers en termes de politique
étrangère un goût pour la politique
étrangère que l'on retrouve chez son
petit fils henry de breteuil le 12 mars
1880 le 8e marc qui reçoit le prince de
galles futur edouard 7 et arrière grand
père d'elizabeth 2 il reçoit aussi léon
gambetta président de la chambre des
députés
cette rencontre qui a lieu chez d'henri
breteuil à la demande du prince de
galles a pour but de jeter les bases de
l'entente cordiale
pour cette amitié franco britannique
qu'il était grand temps de réaliser
cette amitié ne sera signé que 23 ans
plus tard en 1904 je vais maintenant
vous présenter la grande dame de la
famille
gabriel est muni de breteuil plus connu
sous son nom de femme mariée
madame du châtelet femmes illustres de
la famille breteuil gabriel emilie est
une mathématicienne du xviiie siècle
longtemps restée connue comme la
compagne de voltaire en fond elle avait
fait promettre à son père de ne pas
l'envoyer au couvent et de recevoir le
même enseignement que ses frères le
grand ouvrage de sa vie a été la
traduction des principes de newton par
newton avait écrit ces principes dans un
latin scientifique extrêmement complexe
que même ses contemporains scientifiques
ne comprenait pas et madame du châtelet
à tous traduits et surtout elle a
commenté et expliqué les principes de
newton
cette traduction française est toujours
la seule à ce jour les visites du
château retrace cette histoire à travers
100 portraits de famille et une
vingtaine de portraits royaux
alors vos aïeuls et leurs invités sont
représentés en statue de cire ce sont
des créations du musée grévin absolument
les neuf premiers personnages du musée
grévin sont arrivés en 1971 avec
notamment marie antoinette louis saez
mon grand père le roi d'angleterre
edouard 7 louis xviii et serra et ça a
été de le début
de lancement finalement du véritable
lancement du château qui nous a pas
permis en 71 de passer de 5000 visiteurs
en 69 première année à 50000 visiteurs
l'année 71 donc il ya des personnages de
cire historique du musée grévin de kars
et jusqu'à mieux j'irai en europe va
trouver mieux plus musée grévin pour
refaire des personnages historiques mais
on a aussi les personnages bien sûr des
contes de perrault les contes de
perrault non par un tout petit peu plus
tard pour revenir sur ces statues de
cire certaines sont actuellement absente
comme la marie antoinette pour cause de
restauration exactement parce que ses
personnages comme les acteurs de cinéma
en quelques heures où les acteurs de
terrain où des danseurs ses personnages
ils ont besoin d'être re m'appuyer la
coiffure doit être revue un petit peu et
c'est pourquoi la scène marie antoinette
louis saez cardinal de rohan varon
bretaye la fameuse scène d'arrestation
du cardinal est en ce moment dans les
ateliers du musée viana et nous sommes
allés avec jean emmanuel pour choisir
d'ailleurs un nouveau costume pour louis
saez et d'ailleurs il a beaucoup de
travail elle a beaucoup de savoir dans
le domaine de la décoration et il a
choisi avec une grande précision des
fils dorés qui devrait à tel endroit
la décoration du saint-esprit qui doit
être mise de telle manière et c'est donc
le tout ça pour dire que c'est un début
avec les quatre c'est celle là mais tous
les autres personnages petit à petit
vont passer à grévin c'est l'année de la
résurrection des personnages de cire
parce que on arrive finalement pas fait
grand chose depuis 50 ans donc il
fallait quand même un nom se lancer là
dessus est ce que vous envisagez d'en
créer d'autres d'amener d'autres
personnages au sens de votre château oui
sûrement alors dans le château même ce
sera vraiment un peu difficile parce
qu'on a on est vraiment au complet
notamment avec des personnages des
cuisines avec emilie
de breteuil voltaire qui est apparue
donc de ce côté là on est quand même
bien remplie avec rousseau sig est
apparu d'ailleurs le musée grévin lui
même vient de faire un art c'est le
proust pour chez lui pour sont visés
tout récemment donc d'autres personnages
dans le château non a priori en revanche
il y a encore un compte qu'il faut
encore moderniser c'est celui du petit
poucet parce que le public maintenant il
a envie d'avoir des personnages qui
bouge avec des télévisions avec des des
évocations très très vivante et j selon
le petit poucet est le dernier à
moderniser ce qui en ferait 8
après il restera peut-être riquet à la
houppe
mais on aura fait tous les comptes
principaux
justement parlons beaucoup des comptes
vous accueillez ici de nombreux enfants
et leurs familles mais aussi dans le
cadre scolaire car l'une des activités
phares de la visite ce sont les contes
de charles perrault et le choix de cet
auteur n'est pas anodin pour votre
chatte ou non leur perron est très liée
à breteil et aux bretelles parce qu'il a
été le bras droit de mon aïeule louis de
breteil dont d'ailleurs tous les
bouteilles descendent celui de breteil
était ministre des finances du roi louis
xiv et il a eu un bras droit qui
s'appelait charles perrault qui était
une sorte de ministre de la culture
chargé des grands travaux et qui s'est
beaucoup occupé notamment des grands
travaux à versailles et des grands
travaux aux tuileries
donc il a eu un rôle essentiel la dent à
l'époque de colvert et était protégé par
colbert et puis par la suite la
politique royale a changé c'est à dire
que louvois est devenu principal
ministre et perrot véritablement est
devenu le grand écrivain le connaissons
et d'auteurs des comptes qui sont parmi
les plus beaux textes qu'on puisse avoir
en langue française et donc ses comptes
comme vous lisiez ont évolué au fil des
années pour se replonger dans leur
évolution un autre sujet regardez
sandrine faudrait une hypothèse tout
grain de pollen
ce jour là c'est peau d'âne qui
recueille le plus de suffrages mais à
breteuil les comptes il y en a huit 8
scènes qui retrace ses histoires de
charles perrault
le dernier né du chaton c'est barbe
bleue et son cabinet interdite qui cache
de lourds secrets pour cette nouvelle
mise en scène les équipes on misait sur
les lumières et la vidéo au coeur de
l'ancien salon de chasse du château il
faut allier la tradition et la modernité
donc à voir les personnages de cire du
musée grévin respecter le lieu dans
lequel la scène est présenté et puis
apporter une vision artistique et les
nouvelles technologies notamment les
effets vidéo lumière le son tout cela
permet de bien de créer une atmosphère
qui j'espère unique une rénovation vingt
ans après sa création l'une des toutes
premières histoires à être comptés sent
bon la galette et le petit pot de beurre
nous sommes ici dans l'ancienne maison
de jeux des enfants de la famille de
breteuil qui a été construite
spécialement pour eux à la fin du 19e
siècle et cette maison a été réaménagé
dans les années 80 au xxème siècle pour
y installer la scène de conte du petit
chaperon rouge qui est un peu la scène
expérimentale c'est à dire que c'est la
peine des premières qui a été installé
ici avec des personnages de cire et puis
en 2012 c'est la première que nous avons
adapté en son et lumière
et bien voici le futur chantier la
prochaine restauration ce sera la
dernière scène de compte en son et
lumière un chantier qui nous attendra
pour 2020 ce petit poucet n'a pas évolué
depuis sa création les équipes
réfléchissent à comment le faire voyager
et vous faire chausser vous aussi les
bottes de sept lieues
[Musique]
alors depuis le début on parlait on voit
beaucoup le château mais il ya aussi un
parc qui l'entourent 75 hectares de
terrain à choisel on y trouve plusieurs
types de jardins des arbres centenaires
c'était aussi la passion de votre épouse
oui alors séverine de voter s'est
passionné pour les jardins tout le temps
elle a elle même créé est d'ailleurs un
jardin que l'on appelle le jardin des
princes que nous apercevons d'ici avec
les cerisiers du japon
ils sont en fleurs ça ne dure pas
longtemps la floraison il faut venir
d'avoir les voir avant la mi avril
parce que ça se termine vite et c'est
grâce un mécénat japonais que nous avons
vu la chance que c'était là mécénat de
la compagnie d'électricité japonaise qui
avait offert au château c'est ces armes
donc que l'on a planté il ya déjà
plusieurs années et miam pas les rides
ya bien sûr un jardin à la française qui
nous entourent qui est l'oeuvre de
duchenne qui était le grand paysagiste
des années 1890 1900 un suiveur de le
nôtre en quelque sorte mais plus tard
mais avec le talent un peu de notre et
puis on les choses très curieuse aussi
dans le parc que tout le monde trouve
qu'elle voit va voir mais c'est un peu
plus loin ce sont les châtaigniers de
l'époque de françois 1er qui vivent
toujours
ce qui est étonnant avec les horribles
donne des feuilles
les troncs sont toujours là et on a
vraiment l'impression de personnages
vivent avec ces armes qui me racontent
cette longue longue histoire qu'il a
correspond à plus de 500 ans et c'est
une grande rareté et de ceux de ce parc
que c'est châtaignier très très anciens
alors vous nous avez donné quelques
indices moi j'ai suivi hélène blanché
qu'il guide conférencière au château
elle nous fait visiter les jardins 75
hectares de jardin classé monument
historique en 1973 le plus grand et le
jardin à la française créée entre 1897
et 1903 henry de breteuil s'adresse aux
duchesne un père et son fils paysagiste
français facile c'est le jardin à la
française construit vers 1900 un parc à
la française est fait pour être vu de
hauteur mais là on a la chance d'avoir
une terrasse qui vous permet même des
jardins de pouvoir le voir en plus haut
et c'est en allant près de la porte
centrale du château que vous serez juste
à la bonne hauteur pour voir ce parc
c'est un jardin comme on les faisait au
xviie siècle un jardin très réguliers
dont par exemple les allées
correspondent à l'extérieur ou au parti
central du château et il ya typiquement
déduit des ifs taille et c'est par
exemple celui ci un grand plan d'eau un
plan d'eau qui les jours de beau temps
reflète le château et ceux qui
l'entourent
à ses côtés un cèdre donné par marie
antoinette à une des dames de breteuil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
passion de séverine de breteuil le
jardin des princes rené en 1991 le
jardin de fleurs et créer à la place de
l'ancien potager avec un esprit xviie
siècle avec tes pièces un peu fermé avec
des charmes par exemple qui permettent
de s'isoler
il ya des allées des plates-bandes avec
des fleurs qui sont certaines des
vivaces et d'autres qui sont changés
régulièrement des annuelles et
il a été réalisé par séverine de
breteuil avec un paysagiste rappeler de
chair qui inspirait de travail de witte
belge en floraison toute l'année ce
jardin possède des variétés spécifiques
pour chaque saison en ce printemps les
stars viennent de très loin comme ses
cerisiers japonais
ils seront bientôt remplacés par les
pivoines henri-françois de breteuil quel
est l'avenir du château
quels sont les 50 prochaines années
écoutez ça c'est une question difficile
moi je crois que l'avenir du château
c'est d'abord de continuer et puis
depuis d'enrichir les animations des
réalisations des travaux dont je vous ai
parlé notamment la faisanderie ce
château est très bien lancé je dirais
maintenant notamment pour le public des
familles pour le believe des enfants les
on a à peu près sur 120 mille visiteurs
payants puisque aussi avec les gratuits
mais on arrive à 135 me je ve règles et
gratuit on a là
sur ses visiteurs on a 60 mille enfants
essentiellement des enfants des écoles
et aussi les enfants avec leurs parents
leurs grands parents que les qu'il ya
des visites scolaires et moi même je
l'accueille sont les visiteurs jeu
samedi
le dimanche les jours fériés et des
toutes les vacances scolaires ce qui
fait que j'estime que je dois et ça me
fait très plaisir
j'aime faire ça je fais ce que vous
appelez dans votre métier
un lancement pour la visite eh bien je
dois facilement avoir voir au moins
personnellement 50000 visiteurs dans ses
lancements et puis on se revoit près
souvent les visiteurs me disent qu'ils
en pensent et ils donnent quelques coins
des idées avancées ce dialogue les
visiteurs et je trouve enrichi sans
merci entre françois de bretagne alors
pour fêter les 50 ans de son ouverture
publique
il a une exposition à découvrir à partir
du 18 mai et toutes les informations
sont sur le site du château
un petit tour d'horizon maintenant des
rendez vous à venir dans les yvelines
[Musique]
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
une conférence spectacle concert mathieu
bauer explore la notion du paysage
sonore il s'interroge en musique sur ce
quai coûtait veut dire regardez
c'est non
m
[Musique]
il désacralise la musique classique le
pianiste jean françois zygel s'empare de
bac 1 bac très apprécié des
improvisateurs notamment les musiciens
de jazz jean françois zygel est à
maurepas le 12 avril et on retrouve bac
cette fois accompagné de vivaldi
tchaïkovski rachmaninov encore bizet à
l'auditorium de la batterie les chefs de
pupitre de l'orchestré de chambre
nouvelle europe vont se succéder pour
jouer trois siècles de musique le
concert débute à 20h30 le vendredi 12
avril et à plaisir vous pourrez partir
au début du 20e siècle aux états unis
pour découvrir le barber shop musique un
chant en harmonie à quatre voix et a
capella un quartet l'adapter en france
rendez vous le vendredi 12 avril ont
déjà fait j'ai ma conscience pour moi je
suis transparent
oui j'ai détourné un peu d'argent chez
mon chihuahua
assistant parlementaire au témoin
philippe propose un jeu à sa femme pour
l'heure 27 ans de mariage de mensonges
et une vérité à dire chacun à l'autre de
trouver quelle est la vérité fausses
pistes vu la thur veine à l'écriture
sébastien blanc et nicolas port et à la
mise en scène jean luc moreau et sur
scène six comédiens dont lionnel astier
et frédéric bouraly regarder viennent
enfin les cas notre homme mon prénom est
mon nom de jeune fille s'en faut qui
fait de la prison il a fait suivre pour
qui tu te prends ça serait mon cheveu
non je me suis moi même ou alors
deuxième hypothèse c'est catherine la
psy copains ce dont je me suis souvent
goûté à magny les hameaux c'est un
week-end 100% culture urbaine qui vous
attendent et 3.0 en herbe et une battle
solidaire toutes les informations sont à
retrouver sur le site de la ville
une avant-première à présent le centre
de musique baroque de versailles et
l'association culture et cinéma vous
invite à découvrir un documentaire il
raconte les dernières semaines d'edward
guy bonhomme à la tête du coeur qu'il a
dirigé pendant 38 ans début de la
projection à 19 heures le mercredi 17
avril
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aulas
c'est la fin de ce site une culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]